el canciller mexicano marcelo ebrard
viajó a washington para reunirse con
altos funcionarios de la administración
baiden en conferencia de prensa desde la
capital estadounidense
ebrard dijo que durante su encuentro con
alejandro mayorkas el jefe del
departamento de seguridad interior este
le hizo ver la preocupación de la casa
blanca por la creciente presión
migratoria que se incrementará aún más
cuando deje de estar en vigor el título
42 este mecanismo que permite las
autoridades estadounidenses de portar de
manera inmediata a los solicitantes de
asilo argumentando razones sanitarias
por la pandemia de kobe 19 interrogado
respecto de que estaría méxico dispuesto
a hacer en este sentido ebrard dijo que
aplicaran sus propias leyes pues méxico
no permite el libre tránsito de
inmigrantes dijo que cualquier persona
indocumentada que desee transitar por el
país deberá registrarse para que el
estado pueda garantizar su seguridad
dijo que habló con mayor cas de instalar
una conferencia en centroamérica para
echar a andar un esquema conjunto de
creación de empleos pues dijo es la
única manera de reducir los flujos
migratorios dijo que también se instala
un grupo de trabajo conjunto para
abordar esta situación asimismo se
reunió con antony blinken secretario de
estado con quien abordó detalles de la
próxima cumbre de las américas manifestó
la intención del gobierno mexicano de
que se invite a todos los países aunque
es sabido que washington no desea girar
invitaciones a los gobiernos de
venezuela nicaragua y cuba